[Musik]
zur Musik von ABBA demonstrieren sie für
Frieden mit Russland gegen die Regierung
und steigende Energiepreise der
Hauptmarkt von Zwickau am 2 Oktober der
DJ auf der Bühne nennt sich happy Vibes
doch statt fröhlicher Stimmung radikale
Parolen gegen die Ampel in Berlin
sie haben uns grundsätzlich und das IDE
ologisch Energiekrise gestürzt um ihre
globalistischen Pläne zu verwirklichen
sie wollen unsere Demokratie und unsere
soziale Marktwirtschaft beseitigen und
eine ölkontiktatur errichten
DJ happy Vibes heißt Andreas Hofmann bei
den Landtagswahlen ist der für die
Partei freie Sachsen angetreten und
holte mehr als zehn Prozent der Stimmen
die rechtsextremistische Partei wird vom
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet laut
Hofmann will Berlin eine Ökodiktatur
errichten Widerstand sei deshalb legitim
jeden Tag
rund 1.400 Menschen marschieren an
diesem Nachmittag durch Zwickau
versammelt hinter dem Banner der
rechtsextremen freien Sachsen
angemeldet wurde die Demo von einer
Gruppe mit unverdächtigem Namen
Volksstimme Bürgerbündnis Zwickau
verantwortlich dafür Mirko rau auch er
ist bei den freien Sachsen sogar am
Vorstand der rechtsextremen Partei
ist extrem eingestuft was bringt sie zu
der Annahme dass sie für das Volk
sprechen also als rechtsextrem
eingestuft wird in Deutschland
eigentlich jeder der was sagt was gegen
den ist was der Allgemeinheit will also
die Volk die volksfo also die
regierungsvorschriften sind also Werder
gegen was sagt wer was neues will wer
Veränderungen will der wird als
rechtsradikal in Deutschland eingestuft
also alles ganz harmlos ganz normaler
Bürgerprotest
neben der Bühne begrüßt Mirko rau
Michael Brück der ist ein bekanntes
Gesicht der rechtsextremen Szene Brück
war Mitglied einer militanten
Neonazi-Gruppe in Dortmund nach deren
Verbot wurde er stellvertretender
Landesvorsitzender der rechtsextremen
Partei die rechte
er betrieb einen Versandhandel Name der
Website Antisemit
2020 zog Bruck nach Chemnitz
mittlerweile ist er im Umfeld der freien
Sachsen aktiv
2019 gibt er ein Interview seine Ziele
eindeutig
wir bekämpfen diesen Start dieses System
mit eben seinen Verantwortlichen und
Systemen muss abgeschafft werden auf der
Demo in Zwickau fällt noch ein Mann auf
Sanni Kujat laut Verfassungsschutzes ein
Rechtsextremist aus Zwickau er
veranstaltete ein illegales Zeltlager
mit Kampfsportlern und war maßgeblich am
rechtsextremistischen Medienprojekt
Jünger Revolution beteiligt
als Anfang September in Leipzig gegen
die Regierung demonstriert wird kommt es
zu Handgemengen mit der Polizei
postet auf seinem instagram-kanal ein
Video aus Leipzig verlinkt den Neonazi
Brück und schreibt wollen wir gemeinsam
den Diskurs mit anders Denkenden
aufnehmen
[Musik]
seit Monaten führen rechtsextreme
Demonstrationen in Zwickau an
mit dabei auch Neonazis und vermummte
potenzielle Gewalttäter
wir fragen nach bei Zwickau aus
Oberbürgermeisterin Konstanze Arndt
wenn sich hier irgendwie freie Sachsen
mit Nazis aus Dortmund treffen und sich
vernetzen das ist doch auch für eine für
eine Stadt eine totale Gefahr oder
ich bin nicht der Verfassungsschutz also
ich kann jetzt keine Auskunft darüber
geben
wie das dort
eingeordnet wird aus meiner Perspektive
heraus sich für so eine extreme
Entwicklung wie sie das gerade
beschrieben haben hier in Zwickau nicht
die
Gefahr da würde ich da klar
widersprechen Benjamin Winkler
beobachtet die rechte Szene in Sachsen
für die amadeo Antonio Stiftung die seit
vielen Jahren rechtsextreme Strukturen
dokumentiert wir haben das Netzwerk wir
haben diese schwache Zivilgesellschaft
zum Teil auch schwache Reaktionen aus
der Verwaltung die diesen
neonazi-strukturen Rechten Strukturen
wenig entgegenzusetzen hat wir haben auf
der anderen Seite aber auch in der
Bevölkerung diese gewisse Anfälligkeit
oder Empfänglichkeit für rechte
Ideologie
Zwickau mehr als zehn Jahre konnten sich
die rechtsextremen Terroristen des NSU
hier verstecken bemerkt hat das niemand
in der Stadt weder Polizei noch
Verfassungsschutz
die Mitglieder des NSU radikalisierten
sich über Jahre auch auf rechtsextremen
Demonstrationen später ermordete das
Trio 9 Menschen aus rassistischen
Motiven und eine Polizistin
wir wissen ja der NSU hat damals ja
Zwickau nicht aus Zufall gewählt als
Unterschlupf sondern weil man genau
wusste man hat dort diese Netzwerke aber
man hat dort auch eine Gesellschaft die
im besten Fall einfach nicht hingucken
bei den aktuellen Demonstrationen ist
die Stimmung aufgeheizt Wut und Hass
Heiligenstadt in Thüringen Anfang
Oktober ein aggressiver Mob bedrängt
Fotografen
wenige Tage später in Wurzen
Demonstranten greifen Journalisten an
Jugendliche
[Applaus]
[Musik]
am 19 Oktober brennt ein Flüchtlingsheim
groß strömkendorf in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern die Feuerwehr
geht von Brandstiftung aus
vorher hatten Unbekannte auf das
Eingangsschild ein Hakenkreuz geschmiert
jetzt ermittelt der Staatsschutz
für den Präsidenten des Thüringer
Verfassungsschutzes Stefan Kramer zeigt
sich auf den Straßen im Osten des Landes
eine bedrohliche Entwicklung
wir haben es hier mit einer völligen
Enthemmung auch von Gewalt und Hass und
Hetze zu tun wir stellen eben fest dass
die Radikalisierung und die Hemmschwelle
auch Gewalt einzusetzen deutlich
gesunken ist
Gera in Thüringen auch hier sehen sich
viele im Widerstand die Deutschlandfahne
auf dem Kopf die Menschen wollen ein
anderes Land Anmelder der Demonstration
ist Christian Klar
Christian Klar zählt zur
rechtsextremistischen Szene in Gera er
ist verurteilt wegen Körperverletzung
klar war Mitglied im Thüringer
Heimatschutz einer militanten
neonazi-gruppierung in der sich auch die
nsu-terrorzelle radikalisierte
haben verstanden dass der Widerstand nur
zusammen erfolgreich sein kann der
Verfassungsschutz hat ihnen im Blick
er tritt dann auch zumeist selber dort
auf mit entsprechenden Beiträgen deren
Radikalität und deren ja Aufrufe auch zu
entsprechende Radikalisierung sind
bekannt und das macht für uns deutlich
dass er eben einer durchaus der
Protagonisten ist der mit größter
Sorgfalt auch angeschaut werden muss
wenn es darum geht zu sehen wohin sich
die Szene weiterentwickelt
Christian Klar ruft auf zum Widerstand
wir wollen von ihm wissen was das für
ihn bedeutet wir werden uns einfach wir
zeigen dass wir uns das nicht gefallen
lassen wie weit würden Sie da gehen mit
dem wären wird sich zeigen
wirklich zeigen
es wird sich zeigen mal gucken Christian
Klar laufen an diesem Tag in Gera mehr
als 2000 Menschen hinterher
wenn man sich dann manche skandierte
Sprüche anschaut dann wird sehr deutlich
wohin die Reise geht das hat nichts mit
legitimer politischer Kritik zu tun
sondern hier wird im Grunde genommen
aufgerufen zur Revolution zum Widerstand
Berlin Pressekonferenz der
bundesinnenministerin hat die
Bundesregierung die Radikalisierung im
Osten des Landes ausreichend im Blick
Nachfrage wie wollen Sie verhindern dass
aus diesen Umsturz Fantasien die dann
ein rechter Terror wird
also ich glaube dass Menschen dieser
Tage natürliches Bedürfnis haben auch
auf die Straße zu gehen bei hohen
Energiepreisen oder auch hohen
Lebensmittelpreisen deswegen war es so
wichtig dass die Bundesregierung
entlastungspakete zur Verfügung gestellt
und zwar mehr als 300 Milliarden Euro
mit Milliarden die Radikalisierung
stoppen Feser glaubt dass das gelingt
nein du bist
nicht in der Mitte der Gesellschaft das
verfängt was von Rechtsaußen kommt in
Thüringen und Sachsen allerdings läuft
die Mitte längst mit bei Demonstrationen
organisiert von Rechtsaußen
sage nur besser wir nehmen es ernst und
es stellt sich nachher als dicke Hose
raus als wenn dem es nicht ernst und
haben dann am Ende doch mehr Opfer zu
beklagen für die kommenden Wochen sind
in Sachsen und Thüringen wieder
Demonstrationen zu erwarten